if you're a bit of a beauty nerd and you
want to know more about your products
here is the perfect event for you beauty
science camp this is a free online event
I'm hosting with beauty cycom we've
gotten some of the top cosmetic science
experts to talk about topics like how to
read an ingredients list do percentages
actually matter how do we make sure
products are safe and you'll have the
chance to ask the experts questions I'm
really excited to be talking about
chemistry and cosmetics I made up a
brand new analogy for this I promise
this is going to make a lot more sense
when I actually explain it you can sign
up for tickets here and hopefully I'll
see you there